bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
fil 78 pour une nouvelle semaine
d'actualité locale voici les principaux
titres de cette édition du lundi 1er
juin
now humanoïde de 58 centimètres en
représentation à l encours et
l'accompagnent les enfants des primaires
collèges et lycées le travail mené cette
année présenté voici quelques jours lors
d'un show interactif c'était au prisme
ay roop solidarités nouvelles pour le
logement va acquérir son millième
logement une barre symbolique pour
l'association qui oeuvre depuis 27 ans
pour aider les familles en très grande
précarité invité aujourd'hui etienne
primard son président et puis vous
découvrirez aussi le latmos le
laboratoire atmosphères milieux
observations spatiales de l'université
yvelinoise qui vient de proposer des
portes ouvertes à guyancourt
ça y est les dinosaures sont à thoiry
préparé depuis plusieurs semaines la
nouvelle et nouvelle vedette du parc
zoologique sont visibles du grand public
depuis ce week end elles ont attiré 4,4
qu'elle 4 quelques 4500 curieux dans
deux jours à dose reproduction de
créatures préhistoriques grandeur nature
confectionnés au texas ont en effet été
disposés pour l'été dans des enclos
paysager et spécialement aménagé une
attraction qui devrait donc bien
fonctionné en plaine et dino magna
puisque dans quelques jours le remake de
jurassic parc jurassique world sera sur
les écrans ce sera à le 15 juin en
france l'avant-première se dérouler est
d'ailleurs vendredi à paris en présence
d'omar sy à l'acte rivlin oies et tient
le rôle d'un dresseur de velociraptor il
était donc sur le tapis rouge avec les
autres acteurs dans un cinéma des champs
elysées il n'a pas manqué de tweets et l
événement vous le voyez nous passons de
la préhistoire au futur maintenant
depuis janvier 2015 d aise élevé l'an
courtois travail en classe avec nao un
petit robot humanoïde une manière
ludique pour faire découvrir la
robotique aux enfants tout en
travaillant de nombreuses notions
scolaire jeudi dernier plusieurs classes
des établissements de la commune
s'étaient rassemblés pour présenter leur
travail mélanie poker et william elle
pour les images font plus tout y
non ils disent qu'une collecte lui toile
exellent
c'est difficile à croire mais cette
interaction ce sont les enfants eux
mêmes qu'ils ont créé cette classe de
cm2 de la commanderie travail avec now
depuis le mois de mars on va faire une
correspondance avec mal pour apprendre
l'anglais et on en a fait un programme
mais sauf qu'on faisait parler now en
anglais ou en français les les deux à la
fois pour les gestes on a tous fait de
nous mêmes avec un détail lines et pour
le faire bouger
nous-mêmes enfin pour par exemple levé
la main à droite cause naos et ce petit
robot humanoïde de 58 centimètres de
haut développé par une société française
trois d'entre eux acheté par la commune
circule entre six groupes scolaires élan
courtois de la maternelle au lycée
près de 300 enfants sont concernés le
projet a été développé en partenariat
avec la direction académique numérique
et l'éducation nationale à travers
canopée le projet informatique dans les
écoles numériques dans les écoles pour
nous date depuis plus de dix ans est
donc l'aboutissement nous a semblé clair
il y a à peu près deux ans quand le
robot nao est sorti avec des
applications éducatif et ça nous a paru
évident de le mettre dans les écoles et
les collèges et les lycées du coup pour
permettre aux enfants d'acquérir les
compétences de codage informatique
on a voulu aussi donner envie aux
enfants de pouvoir avoir accès à ce
robot nao
pour avoir plus d'enfants qu'ils aient
envie d'aller vers les sections
scientifiques côté notions mathématiques
programmation français anglais mais pas
seulement
ça leur a permis de vraiment de
comprendre que tout ce qui nous entoure
aujourd'hui ne fonctionnerait pas sans
la main de l'homme quand même puisque là
effectivement ils ont bien vu que pour
une seule
enfin une ou plusieurs questions ça leur
prenait quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
temps donc si on imagine pour tout ce
qui est autour de nous est effectivement
beaucoup de travail
j'aimerais encore un plus avoir de
choses parce que je comprends pas tout
est d'être dans le métier avec now on
peut aussi s'amuser
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il a l'oeil
2015 année de la lumière un thème choisi
par l'unesco à cette occasion
laboratoire atmosphères milieux
observations spatiales latmos de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines vient d'ouvrir ses portes
mélanie poquet et even berger mais quand
on fait ça simplement ce que l'on voit
elle se décompose et on vous et on voit
aussi 7,7 cette lumière lorsqu'on a un
arc en ciel par exemple un simple prise
une lampe et voici ce qu'appellent les
scientifiques elle les longueurs d'onde
la lumière est au coeur du travail des
chercheurs du laboratoire atmosphères
milieux observations spatiales la
lumière on a choisi de lui présenter
et de rappeler que la lumière blanche en
fait elle est composée d'un grand nombre
de couleurs et donc on va des couleurs
ultra violets finalement qui affecte la
peau et dont l'ozone quel point qu'alain
gascous intéresse est un élément très
important en passant par le visible et
donc tous les phénomènes visibles
lumineux qui nous permettent
d'appréhender comment fonctionne à deux
posters jusqu'au à l'infrarouge qui est
aussi la couleur que l'on voit pas et
qui est fondamental pour les aspects
climat pour identifier ces infrarouge
dans cette expérience on utilise une
caméra résultats de la manipulation les
lunettes absorbent les rayons
contrairement aux sacs plastiques est-ce
que l'atmosphère c'est l'équivalent de
la ville où c'est l'équivalent de ce
salon c'est comme la vitre d'accord
parce que clairement lorsqu'on est à la
surface de la terre en tant qu'organe le
soleil on le voit très bien la caméra
infrarouge m'a beaucoup amusé
je savais pas par exemple que voilà que
que des choses invisibles pouvait
devenir visibles quand on les regardait
différemment donc avec cette caméra
je m'intéresse à la recherche et je
voulais savoir comment on accède aux
métiers de la recherche est ce qu'on
fait dans ce métier et lors de ces
journées portes ouvertes on ne pouvait
passer à côté de rosetta et fila et la
mission européenne qui a connu son point
d'orgue de 12 novembre 2014 avec le thé
les sages du petit robot une mission à
laquelle a collaboré le latmos le
laboratoire fort de six départements
regroupe 230 personnes
invité du journal en ce lundi etienne
prima bonsoir ou bonjour vous êtes seul
le président de solidarité nouvelles
pour le logement association qui oeuvre
depuis 27 ans auprès des familles en
difficulté en région francilienne
samedi près de 2 600 personnes se sont
retrouvées à l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
pour célébrer son action autour de
tables rondes de représentations
théâtrales également on va déjà bien re
situer les choses comment fonctionne
cette association solidarité nouvelles
pour le logement
le principe c'est d'acquérir des
logements est proposé à bas coût voire
gratuitement à les familles le principe
est de trouver des logements accessibles
au niveau du loyer et des charges pour
les gens en grande précarité
on ne pouvait pas à louer au prix du
marché ensuite sourire 6 euros du mètre
carré ce serait une perte eux donc la
seule solution est à était d'acquérir de
réhabiliter ou de construire et
éventuellement quelques mises à
disposition avec des bourgs de longue
durée bon fit aux tic venant des des
pouvoirs publics où nous des privés
beaux arts et habitations mais comment
tout cela a été rendu possible de
pouvoir créer ces logements justement à
faible à faible loyer légère folie oui
déjà folie au départ nous étions mais
qui a fait ses preuves en 27 ans de voix
la solution que nous étions quelques
quelques amis a déjà être très habitués
à faire de l'hospitalité bien accueillir
les gens qu'on pourrait rencontrer et
qui étaient exclus de tout logement
les lieux que nous nous donnons pas à
dire la possibilité était beaucoup trop
réduit nous avons forcés de nous
agrandir en fer denis sa femme à paris
moi et ma femme en essonne nous avons
démarré avec nos amis en disant qu'il
fallait qu'on achète des logements écran
les loups un prix tout à fait
raisonnable puisque ces trois à quatre
fois moins cher que dans le privé
aujourd'hui 8300 personnes ont été
accueillies dont près de 1000 logements
que sont devenus ces personnes parce que
le but c'est de les relancer dans la
société aussi on s'appelle solidarités
nouvelles à le but c'est que les
locataires soient aussi solidaires que
nous c'est à dire que quand il vaut
mieux qu'ils laissent la place à
d'autres qui vont plus mal ce qui permet
une certaine rotation donc comme vous
dites oui plus de 1300 personnes ont été
logées
la plupart des départs se font dans les
hlm
certains en accession à la propriété
d'autres mort précoce ou éventuellement
départ sur le site adresse en moyenne
ces trois ans à peu près à peu près est
ce que c'est une durée qui s'est étendue
qui a évolué au fur et à mesure des
années depuis 25 ans ça dépend des
départements dans lesquels nous sommes à
paris c'est très difficile de trouver
des logements de sortie accessible à nos
personnes qui sont encore très démuni
quand elles sortent de chez nous
et ça dépend des accords que nous avons
avec notamment les réservataires des hlm
c'est à dire la préfecture et puis les
bailleurs eux mêmes et les communes
puisqu'elles ont des réservations
l'association à 27 ans à 27 ans d'action
on va continuer à en parler on va juste
faire une pause parce que nous sommes
allés dans les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines aujourd'hui à votre rencontre
avec notre question du jour est il plus
difficile de se loger qu'auparavant
rencontrez vous des difficultés vos
réponses je vois beaucoup de
constructions de logements mais ensuite
je suis pas du tout au courant des
moyens d'acquisition je connais
plusieurs de mes amis qui cherchent à se
loger et qui voudraient bien changé de
deux logements en est en location et
pour qui c'est extrêmement compliqué je
pense que le principal problème c'est le
coût je crois que pour les jeunes c'est
un peu compliqué mais comme partout en
région parisienne ça pose des problèmes
on a besoin de logements mais le
problème c'est qu'on n'a pas les
infrastructures pour enfin ces logements
moi je trouve que non ça va parce qu'ils
ont moins bien de prendre un appartement
là voisins bretons nu et on n'a pas eu
de difficulté à trouver
et du coup c'est un bien qui
construisent justement de nouveaux
logements alors la situation elle valait
compliqué parce que c'est un peu une
abordable pour un un foyer moyen avec
des revenus lambda après pour quelqu'un
qui a effectivement qui fait les
logements elles sont accessibles pour
les cadres supérieurs voire très
supérieurs le logement on en parle avec
l'association francilienne solidarités
nouvelles pour le logement
on parlait de justement de ces personnes
que vous accueillez qui sont ensuite
relogés derrière qui arrivent à se
réinsérer dans le cycle seca 93% à peu
près de relogement tout donc c'est un
vrai succès sur le modèle que vous avez
réussi à mettre en place
quel est le profil des gens qui viennent
parce qu'on voit tout le monde ne pas
confronter de la même manière aux
difficultés de se loger on l'a entendu
en schématisant il ya un peu deux
profils différents il ya les gens qui
viennent de l'extérieur les immigrés et
puis il ya les français qui font des
français
les gens de chez nous qui sont en
difficulté depuis plusieurs générations
parfois et qui ont forcément du mal à
retrouver un certain équilibre retrouvé
une certain certain lien social
parce que c'est leur passé lourd
certains certains africains certains
pubs et des gens des pays de l'est ce
que l'on reçoit ont une envie très forte
de s'en sortir et s'en sont moins
marquées ont été marqués dans leur pays
s'ils ont dû le quitter mais une fois
arrivés chez nous ils ont souvent plus
de facilité tous tous n'ont pas de
logement quand ils viennent chez nous
donc ils viennent soit de deux lieux
squattés soit d'hôtel soit de la rue
soit le plus souvent aussi en
suroccupation dans leur famille ou chez
des amis mais on parle des difficultés
des plus jeunes pour accéder au logement
parle aussi des difficultés des
personnes âgées qui se trouve de plus en
plus isolé j'imagine que vous voulez
retrouver aussi qu'elles viennent vous
voir
on retrouve même les personnes âgées
propriétaire qui avec leur retraite
n'arrivent plus à payer leurs charges
donc le ya moyen tout bête qu'on peut
tout à fait faire avec elle c'est
d'acheter leurs biens ce qui leur donne
un petit pécule pour vivre plus
agréablement ensuite de leur faire un
logement confortable dans ce bien
souvent un pavillon où un grand logement
et puis ensuite de disposer d'un ou deux
autres logements à côté pour d'autres
personnes en difficulté voilà des choses
j'ai durée hâtivement simple et qui leur
permettent de vivre beaucoup mieux ce
week-end vous vous étiez réunis à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines il y avait des bénévoles on
va parler du travail des bénévoles aussi
il y avait des bénéficiaires des
locataires qui était présent je vous
propose d'écouter le témoignage d'une
locataire elle a trois enfants elle
réaliserait résident près de chevreuse
depuis un an maintenant ça fait un an
que tu dans une maison snl je vais dire
que c'est très bien ça aide beaucoup de
gens je suis venu avec mes trois enfants
j'ai mes bénévoles qui m'ont aidé et qui
m'ont épaulé depuis que je suis rentré
dans le snm je suis arrivé sans rien et
maintenant je suis bien avec mes enfants
j'ai
et ils m'ont accompagné aussi par
rapport je voulais faire des formations
et accompagne moralement comme
physiquement et bien
j'ai créé un relation très forte avec
des bénévoles je me suis retrouvé à la
rue je crois sans ça mais grâce à ça oui
je suis dans un logement et que j'ai une
forte chance et j'ai conscience que je
vais je vais aller dans une logement
durable
on l'a entendu il n'y a pas que l'aspect
logement il ya tout un accompagnement et
ça c'est le travail des bénévoles
le trail des vols et des travailleurs
sociaux de l'association les bénévoles
sont présents pour assurer un
accompagnement qu'on appelle de
proximité c'est à dire ils sont présents
régulièrement avec attention avec
bienveillance auprès des personnes que
nous le jean et potasse ait chez nous
elle ne meurt plus de 2 de froid ou de
chaud puisque autant de gens de la
rumeur en été qu'en hiver mais elles
sont encore dans une immense solitude
etc c'est le lien qu'on essaye de
recréer par les bénévoles qui la plupart
du temps ce sont des voisins
les opérations immobilières que nous
réalisons donc c'est donc une
intégration dans la vie de quartier
autant que faire se peut j'ai forcément
les villes recréer du lien c'est
important aussi pour redonner confiance
à chacun jours pour continuer une
soutenance réciproque se réunir pour
ensuite relever le défi qui est
l'accession à l'agent durable de leur
commun et je suis un défi inouï puisque
quand on est en dessous d'un
reste-à-vivre décembre les bailleurs ne
pas ne pas donc quelques 1200 bénévoles
à travers la région francilienne est
aussi des salariés 70 cents pour
solidarité solidarité logement nouvelle
solidarité on va écouter un une des
bénévoles de l'association justement que
nous avons aussi rencontré ce week end
les gens qu'on accueille c'est pas
toujours le cas mais parfois c'est quand
même des gens qui sont assez cassé qui
ont justement plus tellement de relation
des ruptures familiales pas d'amis ou
très peu et donc en fait les bénévoles
ils sont vraiment là pour recréer du
lien faire que ces personnes se sentent
moins isolé et du coup après bombe à la
relation elle elle va être ce que les
gens ont envie qu'elle devienne il va y
avoir des relations fortes des amitiés
il va y avoir au contraire des relations
plus d'être plus distendus moins propre
ça dépend complètement de des rencontres
et c'est en ça que c'est intéressant et
ça permet vraiment aux gens de retrouver
un fonctionnement normal ordinaire de
liens avec avec des voisins avec des
proches avec dans une dans une ville le
système que vous avez mis en place
fonctionne a fait ses preuves depuis 27
ans et vous dites que cela coûte même
moins cher que pour les pouvoirs publics
que des centres d'hébergement d'urgence
ou encore des hôtels dont on peut se
demander pourquoi c'est pas plus
développé encore ça fait 25 ans que je
m'évertue à rencontrer successivement
les ministres du logement qui se
succèdent
voilà à chaque fois ils disent mais
monsieur renard vous avez raison il faut
qu'on mette un effort sur le logement
d'abord et non pas le parcours
résidentiel
voilà des habitudes sont prises c'est
vrai que le parcours résidentiel la nuit
d'hôtel ensuite le logement d'urgence
ensuite l'hébergement parce que l'hôtel
soit à peu près six mille 6000 euros
pour les pouvoirs publics pour une
famille alors que ça coûte environ 2700
euros 1500 euros pour l'accompagnement
avec le système que vous avez mis en 10
à 10 comme vous l'avez dit le trader 93%
drisht en plus voilà ce sont les
chiffres mais on parlait de ces
logements bientôt mille logements ça
fait une cinquantaine de logements par
an là aussi comment ça fonctionne
comment vous réussissez acquérir ces
logements parce qu'il faut des
ressources des revenus aussi à des dons
mais ça suffit pas forcément grâce
évidemment à nos partenaires qui chante
nombreux les partenaires publics qui
abondent par des subventions quand on
est partenaires publics l'état le
conseil régional sont très engagés les
conseils généraux selon les départements
plus ou moins et puis ensuite la commune
et puis la force de snl c'est surtout
les dons privés qui compte pour au moins
25 % des acquisitions et bien sûr donc
on nous empruntons très peu ce qui
permet des loyers accessibles aux plus
riches
mais ce sont 115 logements qui sont
proposés dans les yvelines 514 dans
l'essonne donc ça change un petit peu
d'un département à l'autre
vous aviez pour conclure un message une
demande particulière concernant les
minimes
oui je profite à une chaudière qui vit
qui viennent nous lâchera là c'est du
concret enchaîné dans un petit immeuble
neuf logements et la fondation les
petites pierres double la mise quand
quelqu'un fait at on donc quelqu'un de
noeuds 50 euros la fondation les petites
pierres point orques double la mise et
il y as pour ceux qui le veulent une
déduction fiscale la fois la snl ti
réunion point org et ça c'est aussi le
site internet de votre association merci
et une chevelure gym revenu en plateau
la suite du journal samedi dernier à
guyancourt c'était la fête de l'enfance
les familles étaient invitées au gymnase
des droits de l'homme pour passer un
après midi avec des animations gratuites
sur le thème du musée de l'imaginaire
william l
elodie moines
guyancourt avant de célébrer les mamans
on s'occupe des enfants
comme tous les ans les familles fuyant
courtoise étaient invités à la fête de
l'enfance sourire maquillage les
déguisements
aujourd'hui pas de règle sauf celle de
s'amuser je suis venu et le musée de
l'imaginaire c'était le thème de
l'événement cette année 23 stands de
troupes de théâtre à travers des
spectacles jeux d'adressé ou de
réflexion il y en avait pour tous les
âges
deux cas on a été chercher du monde on a
dessiné gars encore entremise 587 et on
a aussi fait des professions de foi une
géante
une journée conviviale et ludique pour
les familles un seul objectif divertir
les enfants mais menée à grands pas mis
à contribution comme sur cette vache de
manège et ce au regard des parents
devaient traire l'animal pour faire
tourner la machine
magnifique vraiment surtout les cloches
à georges j'en sais un peu comment ça
s'appelle en france elle et les cloches
pour le mhr y avait un mot je crois pour
sauver mon fils est ravi qu'il ya des
enfants qui se retrouvent entre eux il
ya les parents qui se retrouvent on
retrouve les instituteurs et des
institutrices et c'est vraiment un
moment qui est très commedia loi le
bouton et la bonne humeur et put
également de la partie cet immense
kermesse en plein air a tout de même
attiré plus de 3500 personnes pour sa
26e édition trappe également à la fête
comme l'an passé à un groupe de jeunes
et d'adultes habitant dans différents
quartiers attrape ont décidé d'organiser
une fête des voisins un moment festif
est important pour les habitants après
les événements tragiques survenus dans
la commune
malgré les événements tragiques qui ont
touché de trappes ces dernières semaines
les habitants ont décidé de réinventer
la fête des voisins c'est un peu à la
base un principe de fête des voisins
mais du coup amélioré c'est vrai que
suite aux derniers événements qui ont pu
se passer sur frappe cette fête elle
fait du bien à tout le monde
et voilà ça montre aussi que les gens
ils peuvent se mobiliser autour d'un ton
festif et convivial et ça fait du bien
souvent beaucoup d'infos négative qu'on
voit des choses de belles choses il faut
en profiter
une grande fête qui avait pour but de
proposer des échanges culturels et du
partage entre les habitants du quartier
car mais ce concert animation et danse
est au rendez vous plusieurs activités
pour les enfants mais aussi les plus
grands celle échange scellé change s'il
n'y a pas d'autre mot aujourd'hui que
les changes l'amitié cette année donc un
manège adultes on a aussi travaillé avec
le centre équestre de la base de loisirs
de saint quentin pour proposer un
baptême de poney
aux enfants les plus jeunes bah c'est
bien on va s'amuser sur les poneys
beaucoup de monde à encore plus de monde
que l'année garde un podium accueille
des spectacles de musique et de temples
du sport à présent les championnats du
monde de triathlon scolaires étaient
programmées ce week end à versailles
autour de la pièce d'eau des suisses 14
nationalités ont participé à cette
compétition des ukrainiens des chiliens
aux côtés des athlètes français le
reportage
un rendez vous exceptionnel versailles a
accueilli le week-end dernier les
championnats du monde de triathlon
scolaire autour de la pièce d'eau des
suisses
au total quatorze nationalités et plus
qu'une centaine de lycéens âgés de 15 à
18 ans participent à cette grande
manifestation
ça se perd ses normes j'ai déjà ses
espérances
en natation chez martial le champion
brésilien américain natation cette fois
avec le groupe des gens tellement des
polonais et des slovaques
dp heureuse que j'avais jamais parlé
avec des virus dans ta vie alors c'est
beaucoup de gens sont des différentes
structures c'est ça c'est bon ça c'est
super et sciences on a l'impression de
voyager alors qu'on est chez nous et que
on connaît les lieux mais c'est
tellement une autre ambiance que c'est
super génial les ukrainiens nous
encourageons nos courses et inversement
pour cette deuxième édition
l'organisation avait programmé un
parcours très technique le parcours il
est assez classique c'est d'abord dans
la pièce d'eau des suisses parcours de
natation c'est ensuite une lutte sur la
route de versailles ici le long du
château qui passe devant la lanterne
rouge
il n'a pas dire du record le vois comme
ça
plutôt dur ce que le vélo il est en faux
plat montant et il ya le vent de face à
l'aller du coup c'est assez dur et les
demi tours sont très serrés donc les
relancer ben on que le coût de sa sas à
pékin et dans ce parcours très technique
ce sont les lycées en français qui sont
sur le mieux sorti la délégation
tricolore a remporté la plupart des
titres les sportifs ont obtenu 8
médailles individuelles dont trois en or
grâce à arthur berlan agathe thibert et
constance millet et prochains
championnats du monde de triathlon
scolaires devraient être au programme et
à porto rico en 2017 et pour l'actualité
sportive du week end au rendez vous dans
quelques instants avec euros et le 7-8
sport comme chaque lundi nous parlions
un cinéma au début du journal et si vous
souhaitez vous aussi vous lancer dans le
septième art sachez que koffi m films
production recherche des figurants de
plus de 25 ans pour une scène qui sera
tourné à magny les hameaux le 18 juin
une scène du fils de joseph d'eugène
green réalisateur notamment du pont des
arts vous avez jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine pour vous manifester à l'adresse
qui s'affiche en envoyant vos photos
septième art toujours et la projection
de la vie des gens d'olivier dû créer ce
mercredi à versailles un film autour de
la dépendance et de l'isolément des
personnes âgées qui suit le travail
d'une infirmière libérale
projection suivie d'une rencontre avec
le réalisateur et le personnel du
service de soins infirmiers à domicile
de la ville de versailles deux derniers
chiffres à vous communiquer pour
conclure cette édition 26200 c'est le
nombre de chômeurs en plus en avril en
france ce qui porte à 3 millions à 500
mille le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
est des chiffres qui viennent d'être
communiquées par pôle emploi le détail
dans les yvelines
dans notre édition de demain mardi aux
mêmes horaires d'ici là je vous souhaite
une très bonne soirée